each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
alright well thanks for coming everybody
I'd like to introduce our speaker for
hey Rhonda who is currently a postdoc at
University of Victoria working with
Daniella Damian and Peggy story at the
same time and he was a PhD student at
university of toronto until a year ago
and has been a post type for one year
and he also has the wonderful resume of
having worked for gina vinalia right
here at microsoft research where he did
some pretty influential work on studying
some exciting things about what software
teams misremember and he currently works
in the areas of looking at collaboration
and coordination amongst the members of
software teams so like to introduce for
hey who's going to talk today about a
study he did on understand the roles in
software organizations thank you hello
everyone and thanks for coming I'd like
to start with it with a picture that
well and they has seen this before
probably you have to because it's been
making the rounds online how how
different people in nit see each other
because I so I mean this is of course in
jest but you can kind of see some of the
stereotypes that people assigned to the
different kinds of roles in in software
organizations right how they see each
other selves always the heroes in all
cases but in different ways and how
everyone else is screwing them up in the
wrong way so the the study that I'm
going to talk about is based on the
observation that that I made a while
back that we we have these terms in our
literature everywhere both in enacting
in an industry we talk about developers
and designers and project or product
managers QA etc but in the firm's that
I've studied and the groups that I've
been to these people apparently are
doing different things that when I often
see in the literature so I'll give you a
sample of of the things these are these
are phrases published in a year or two
ago in the academic literature and some
of them kind of deer to what I was
expecting to find from you know the
concept that people have on roles in
software organizations but some do not
so for instance the first one someone
says non-functional requirements are one
of the hardest problems analysts and
designers have to deal with during
software design and I agree that
software designers have to be thinking
of non functional departments all the
time but it's just that I've never seen
them doing them doing it purposefully
right to say now I'm going to work on
non functional requirements another on
the similar on a similar vein developers
identify and manage work dependencies
again it's something that I guess they
need to be doing in their in their daily
work but it's it's weird for me to see
it spelled out like that because I've
never seen a developer discuss
dependencies
specifically right a weirder one if a
software architect has to model a
concern not supported by his own
language or tool this is something that
I've never seen I've never seen a
software architect modeling concerns at
all no matter what it will actually
haven't seen anybody modeling concerns
just a few more users hardly get any
support in creating process models okay
that's that's an understanding of what a
user does that does not match my own our
proposal provides software designers
quantitative feedback they can use to
meet a coverage goal so software
designers I think in here is being used
as a term to refer to software
professionals in general and how they
want you know testing coverage but a lot
of people have associated label designer
with something very different than you
know establishing the quality of a piece
of code and so now let's keep the last
one that the point is that in general
reading the literature on software
engineering I get the this feeling that
we're talking about different things
that people talk about a developer or a
tester or project manager with a meaning
very different from the one that I have
and the one that I've seen so I said
well I might be wrong to right maybe
maybe my conception of what a software
developer is or what a tester is is is
very inaccurate so I wondered you know
would it be a good idea to study what
are the actual roles in software
development organizations and do we even
have a consensus or they are there
common well-established roles in the
industry or do they vary a lot across
organizations and even or even within an
organization the roles change over time
in a group and if so why why what are
the reasons that people change their
responsibilities
do people in different roles use the
same tools and do they use them in a in
a similar way and also what we're doing
position is fit in the picture right is
your title directly related to what
you're actually doing or not so i
started i started doing this this study
without really knowing if this was a
problem that needed to be fixed maybe
it's not die before starting I I hadn't
heard complaints from anyone that said
oh well our our distribution of labor is
completely ambiguous and this is leading
to lots of problems and what I didn't
want to do was to end this study with a
proposal for some kind of
standardization or certification or
something like that if you want to
become a software tester you know these
are the things that you should be doing
and if you want to be a project manager
these are the things that you should be
doing but I think there are good reasons
to study rolls in in in software
organizations mainly because they are
related in several ways to real concerns
that managers and software professionals
have so were the right ratios of
different kinds of professionals in a
group for instance let's say developers
and testers now by the way you can feel
free to interrupt me any anytime you
want often company policy is very
detached from what's actually happening
how can we bring it closer together so
that what what's stated in the in the
formal policy makes sense in practice oh
but by more consistent with what's
actually happening in a team so to give
an example let's say that the policy
states that requirements are written in
the form of a requirements document
written by an analyst and passed on to
designers and developers and in actual
practice
maybe there's a lot of people bypass
that that process so you know it's
important to if you care a lot about
having policy that's consistent to
practice something needs to be changed
there so that's what I mean and also
from from an academic perspective it's
it's good to have some conceptual
clarity right we're talking a lot about
these concepts almost every abstract in
TSE or exceed or FSC you know mentions
one kind of software professional so it
would be good at least to you know have
a better understanding what are we
talking about so the first thing I did
was to go back to sociological
literature and organizational science
literature to see how how they conceived
of roles in social groups it's an old
topic for them right and the consensus
seems to be that a role is or what we
what the color role is an abstraction
that we use to refer to a set of
expectations placed on someone okay the
key word here is expectations so the
role is kind of like at the molecule
level but the expectations are the atoms
that really constitute it so whatever a
person is expected to do by virtue of
their their position their status or
their history their preference all of
that defines the role this means that
rolls our social construct there is a
developer's whatever the relevant social
group determines that a developer
shooting right so a researcher at
Microsoft Research is whatever the group
decides perhaps unconsciously or
unintentionally that the researcher
should be
this also means that there is no
prototypical anything there's no
prototypical researcher or developer or
tests or anything because these concepts
are defined at the group level and who
places these expectations while everyone
teammates so so for instance you have
someone who is a developer what is at
being a developer mean well it means
what the teammates think that the
developer should be doing what their
supervisors and maybe subordinates think
that they should be doing people they
interact with also people they don't
interact with but with which with whom
they have some some some kind of
relationship so people who let's say in
Microsoft you could have lots of
developers and who are unknown to
another another division of the
department salespeople or whoever sales
people don't haven't interacted with any
developer in particular but they are
expecting something to happen in the
development group and that expectation
is transferred into the into the actual
developers society in general also
placed some expectations and of course
the the person who is enacting the role
also has some expectations on what is it
I should be doing given that my social
group is is giving me this role
so there are some problems that come out
of this conceptualization that the first
one is that the set of expectations of
all of these people is probably not
consistent or satisfiable even right I
get some expectations from from my
buzzes and from my peers and from from
other people and there may be no way to
make everything satisfiable so solid
sociologists call this role strain
you're being you're being stressed by
the different pools that you have on you
and it may lead into it may lead to this
function so people are expecting you to
do something you can't satisfy that
something and so there is a consistent
mismatch between the expectations placed
in you and your behavior the other the
other interesting thing is that since
these expectations arise from the group
that you're a part of that means that
there's no guarantee that they match
those expectations placed on someone
with a similar role somewhere else now
in some professions the the roles and
expectations are much more uniformly
understood so for instance in the
medical domain we can we can talk up
doctors and nurses anesthesiologists and
surgeons and just naming them you can
have a bunch of expectations of what is
it that they should be doing what
constitutes normal behavior and abnormal
behavior for from them but in our field
I I claim that the expectations are not
that uniformly understood that there's a
lot of variation and we're going to see
a few reasons why yes what I asked
before since
certain professions are more amorphous
and 20
can ask these questions what you're
saying medical field
like factory workers
yeah not much leeway what their roles
haha so
have you found other professionals that
are more similar to software or
musicians
yeah that's a good question I didn't I
didn't specifically look for others that
are similar but I I can come up with
some because I i think these this
amorphous ness is that a word comes from
a number of factors I'm going to be
going over over some of those factors
but briefly to anticipate that the main
driver for uniformity is
institutionalization right so the more
institutionalized some role is in the
larger culture the more that every
instantiation of that role will fit that
picture so if if we have for instance if
we demanded that every software
developer had a license or certification
or something you would expect to see a
lot more uniformity but i'll be going in
more detail on this
right so the other the other wrinkle
here is we need to make a distinction
between roles and positions a position
or a title is what you know what the
business card reads and sometimes
they're the same thing you could be a
software developer in practice you know
you could be developing production code
and at the same time have a business
card that says software developer but
these things don't necessarily match and
we so sociologists make a distinction
between one you know a position you
occupy a role you enact position is
based on a formal policies and a role is
based on the norms of behavior in social
group so just something to keep in mind
i'll come back to this woody allen here
is the president of some banana republic
he has the official position of
president but his role was slightly
different if you saw the movie right so
so that was a brief overview of the
theoretical framework that that we
sketched out coming from the
sociological literature then we what we
decided to do by the way this is work
that I did in collaboration with Adrian
Adrian Reuter and a general adamian and
pig story we decided to do a field study
to test out this theoretical framework
and try to modify a little bit if
observations didn't match our
expectations so it was a case study of
two organizations and I need to tell you
a little bit about both organizations
because a lot of the examples i'm going
to give in a few minutes use information
from from those organizations so they're
both small fairly small especially for
Microsoft centers they're pretty pretty
damn small about 50 people the first one
and 25 the second one the fifty people
one which I'll call company a is it does
software for bioinformatics
it has a development team of 17 people
mostly developers some testers these
group is subdivided in development teams
and they have about 30 something folks
doing other kinds of stuff sales field
support project management product
management they have like five VPS this
company's was by the time I I went to
spend time with them I spent three weeks
with them they were going over a rough
patch they had a downsizing two weeks
before I arrived they lost I think about
15-20 people but it was the second
downsizing they had the economic comfort
so things weren't going super for them
it was interesting for us because we
could see you know how responsibilities
were changing as people were adapting to
their new situation the second group
which I'll call Company B although it's
not really a company it's a publicly
funded group it's part of a research
institute and they're tasked with
providing data and data analysis
services to scientists all over Canada
and because they do it over the Internet
and the Internet has no real boundaries
to scientists all over the world so they
receive data from a bunch of places and
they process it on site and they develop
software to help people access it mine
it store versions of it etc so it's a
smaller group and its subdivided in
three in three parts we have the
development side software developers
which are about eight people if I
remember correctly they have scientists
a bunch of scientists who also do a
little bit of development mostly scripts
and they have operations an Operations
Group which is charged with providing
data and
services and ensuring that that they
have a good uptime and that everyone's
data is safe and so on all right so I
spent in total five weeks at at both
places i conducted 36 interviews of
about an hour each that comes to about
fifty percent of the total staff at both
sites and so we ended up with a bunch of
stuff a lot of a lot of examples that it
cannot be summarized very very easily
but we also came up with with this table
which I know you won't be able to read
I'm sorry about that I I couldn't come
up with a better way to explain it so
what is this this is we got a lot of
information from people when I when I
ask them okay what what is it that you
should be doing here what are you
expected to do if you go what's going to
happen to the organization what do you
expect from other people etc right and
so then I analyze all that and I came up
with this list of expectations that that
people have and the original list was
much longer but some of the expectations
were too detailed and so I removed them
because I was looking for something more
universal to share and I also clustered
the expectations by area so you have the
technical core the first few rows or the
technical core which means you know
actual development of software fixing
bugs maintaining legacy code and and
script scripts that that or
customizations that you need to do on
the base systems and then in the in the
columns in here you have a bunch of
people which I'm mostly classified by
their positions more than by their roles
although I made a couple of exceptions
for instance the second company had did
not have official team leads but two
people were really doing more
team-leading stuff so I put them over
here in NH clustering here you can see
a small subdivision that means company 1
and company too and each of these
squares is colored by how much people
expect that person to do something right
so why it means we don't expect you to
do this light gray means or gray means
you're somewhat expected to do this and
a black means you're highly expected to
do this now this is subjective this this
comes from interview data my
interpretation of that interview data
but I'll go back to this because I think
this could be the basis for some more
objective analysis or at least more of a
self-reported analysis of expectations
in software groups anyway a few patterns
that I think are interesting here yeah
these those people you interviewed
perceptions of our expectations of what
other people thought that they should do
or does it also combine what they found
yeah both both now mind you this is this
is only the people that I talk to if I
included everyone in both organizations
the table would be twice as long but I
had less information for the people that
I didn't talk to so I left those out
this is a subset of of all the people in
both organizations like doing the road
boy positions that you didn't have
temperature No so I tried talking to
people in every group yeah yeah I did um
well one exception there's a significant
sales team in company one and I didn't
talk to any of the salespeople and
there's a sysadmin at company one as
well I didn't talk to the system min but
other than that I covered all the
group's yeah when you ask them about
expectations of others were they
referring to individual people like jump
like I expect John to be a developer to
write code as opposed to all developers
whoever they are yeah so so I was
looking for the first kind of response
you know John should be doing this I
often got a often first got the second
kind of response developers should do
this and if that if that was the case
and I would push them and say okay
who-who in development should should be
doing this and that's that's what I went
with yeah I notice that you mixed QA and
offset you also mentioned system it's
yes maybe subset of prep in some cases
what was the butcher
yeah a practical reason actually which
is that I only had one person from ups
and looking at what that person was
doing it had a lot to do to do with I'll
explain that in a moment but allowed to
do with quality assurance as well so I
just lumped that person together with
the others so really it was a small
sample size really sounded
there wasn't a lot of operation
he has a specific discipline and
that's right so remember the the one
company that had operations an
Operations Group there were four people
in that group and the information you
see here is from the head of that group
which is the person I interviewed yeah
start most by places that you get most
uniformity and most right exactly so oh
what a few of the interesting patterns
that I that I came up with the first one
is this this cluster here around the
technical core and how you can spread
out of working on the technical core in
two main ways you can either spread out
the way that the tech leads do by the
signing system architecture taking the
toughest problems and providing some
historical perspective you kind of
become a bit of a team historian or the
other one the the path of the team leads
which is more towards management
reporting what the team is doing and so
on so that's one another one is you
can't really see it very well in the
table but there are very few people that
have expectations placed in the
technical side in the in the management
side and and in providing some domain
legitimacy or being you know domain
experts let's see if I can find so this
one for instance this this person works
a lot with with directors in determining
the long-term vision for the product
provides the main legitimacy to the
organization I'll explain what that
means in a moment also is working
coordinating product release writing
documentation and and and so on so that
person is all over the place those
people were very rare but in the
interviews other people constantly refer
to them as key for the organization to
keep on keep on going right for one of
those I think it's this person who is
again all over the map
someone said well if that person leaves
we may just you know close the doors and
and turn off the lights because there's
nothing else we can you can do any here
for a jog link under maintain legacy
code and the developers uh yeah larger
organization right varies from black to
white yeah what it's like advocate for
resolution of use your customer problems
yeah it's all black or gray for
everybody in this it's either it's true
right they're not this variance now I
should warn you not to read too much
into the actual details because this is
only half of the organization's right
but you're right and I can explain this
is this thing here in that larger
organization remember there's there
several sub teams and one team was
charged with the the main the main
product that they were working on which
was kind of old and difficult to work
with and so a lot of what they were
doing was just solving bugs and working
on the road map features that they have
the company also wanted to move away
from that and so they had they created
this splinter group that shouldn't be
concerned at all with legacy code
whatsoever and you know they had
supposedly a blank slate to be working
on so that that's that's the reason why
will you go gently
questions were about specific people yes
right yeah
and just one more pattern there were
some expectations that are very weakly
spread all throughout the organization
so for instance writing low level or you
need to test code a lot of people have
that expectation weekly it's like
everyone says oh yeah well we should
write unit tests we should all we should
all ensure that our code is fine or
documentation yes we're all in charge of
documentation but nobody's really
charged with it you know it's just
everyone expects everyone else to play
nice and do some of this yeah when
you're asked about expectations address
also how significant that expectation
was for that person for that role
and whether or not that person will
speed their expectations yeah so yes I
did both although not not always
systematically but so sorry the first
part is whether yours how important is
that expectation to that person like is
that it's a good part of their job or is
that yeah they just kind a lot of time
doing this and testing writing test code
yeah play important to them yeah I
should also add that I also spent time
observing what what they were doing
right and so you know I interview
someone and they say oh yeah we should
unit test and then you know I talk to
the QA person and I say do you have a
set of unit tests to start with or no of
course not nobody's writing them you
know that kind of thing so you also as
usual I you should i usually get
conflicting accounts and it's you know
it's it hard to determine where reality
is yeah anyway so as you see there are
some patterns and you can kind of
classify a little bit of you know what
what people are doing based on their
expectations but there's also a lot of
role variation sorrel murder solving
detectives but everyone does it their
own way so so just like we have that
with them it was difficult for me to
find people with the same roles
insignificant detail in the
organizations that I that I studied and
I wanted to give you a couple of
examples of that and an important
exception so in company one there were
three people that were doing product
management stuff everyone called them
product managers but and I talked to all
three of them and they were doing it
very differently each of them so the
first one was mostly doing actually
product design he was concerned with a
little bit of the architecture talking a
lot of with with tech leads and so on
the second one for a different team so
they were each of them working on
different teams second one was mostly
working on you
a documentation way of doing product
management trying to specify the
architecture the api's of the of the
systems writing the documentation
himself and so on and the third one had
a more external facing kind of product
management so what what he did remember
this is a bioinformatics company he had
a PhD in bioinformatics and was doing a
lot of you know talking with clients
figuring out what they wanted and trying
to bring that into into V into the
development so free product managers
three very different ways of doing it
the same thing happened with with team
leads everyone had a different kind of
set of expectations of what they should
be doing a sting leads with developers
some people had to do more documentation
some people had to do more requirements
and design some people were just
expected to take this this description
and produce code that matches these this
specification the one important
exception to these role variation
finding was project managers at the
first company a company one I talked to
22 of them and I have served the third
one at work and by the way there were
just three but all three were doing
pretty much the exact same thing the
variations were were there but we're
minut and when I talked to them and
asked why are you you know I talked to
them late in the in the study and I was
a bit surprised to see such uniformity I
asked him why why is that the case and
and they said that it was intentional
and part of it comes from a
certification so all of these are
project management professionals PNP's
so they have the certification there
have their body of knowledge and their
processes and they were actively trying
to enforce their own interpretation of
what a project manager should be doing
in the organization into everyone else
so this is the way we are going to work
here are probably
is and you know get on with program
right so that was an interesting
exception to to this row variation
everyone else was kind of like mucking
around but project managers were fixed
on an idea of what they should be doing
okay so I'll go back once live an
interesting question for us was what
makes some people and here take some
expectations why our expectations
clustered in the ways that they are and
not in others and so we came up with
four kinds of factors that make certain
people attract some kinds of
expectations or some expectations and
not others the first kind of factor is
institutional and this is what what I
was talking about earlier this is the
case of the project managers for
instance there is a relatively strong
institution of what a project manager
should be doing if you're trained like
that you come into an organization
you're told you're a project manager and
you know what to do right but the same
thing happens to some degree with other
with other roles so for instance tester
you know if you're hired hired into a
company as a tester even without anybody
telling you anything you say well I mean
I guess I should be writing some tests
right I should be should be checking the
quality of the code that people pass on
to me and when other people here that
you are a tester they expect certain
behaviors from you so this comes from
the larger culture from from our
institutions of what software
organization is like I have an example
of this coming from a company one for
several years the company was just
chugging along as a start-up growing
kind of organically I'd hit about 15 to
20 people and then they acquired a lot
of venture capital after acquiring
venture capital they had to change their
ways the venture capitalists expected
this so they have to put in a CEO a
bunch of VPS they needed a sales group
because every self-respecting software
company should have sales group
need to have project managers a product
management department QA Department
resource a human resources department so
all of these structure just came into
the organization externally it's just
what a company like this was expected to
be doing by the venture capitalists this
probably was not the wisest move for
them I don't know but but but it is an
example of how you know the larger
culture effects what what you're doing
internally yes two companies have
training programs for new hires like if
you hire somebody as a test for you
teach them what it means to be a tester
in your organization and vegetables use
now to a very limited extent the only
ones that have that are developers and
the training is done by other developers
for instance they have a wiki with
problems to get you started right so so
you know the first thing you need to do
is to be able to build and our system
here are the instructions first day your
or whatever wherever whichever day
you're supposed to do that then after
that you know make these small
notifications see what happens and so on
some teams have that better structure
than others a second kind of factor that
affects how expectations are clustered
is you know historical factors so you
know like a tree you bend it some way if
it doesn't die it just keeps on growing
that way or like for instance you have a
patch of lawn people start to walk over
it in the you know in the same ways and
suddenly you have a path and one day
someone decides to pave that path it
becomes official so that's that's the
thrust of what I'm talking about here
the expectations that people have inner
group partly come from what they used to
be doing before or other people in
acting the role used to be doing before
for instance at company one there was
when there was all this expansion is VC
funded expansion going on there was a
guy that they hired for the QA lead
position and later moved on to become a
program manager when the layoffs came in
they gave him a choice Twitter go out or
become a tester a QA analyst he decided
to take the ladder but at the same time
this this guy knew a lot of what was
going on at a higher level in the
organization he was still while I was
there even though he was a QA analyst he
was invited and participated in
decisions that did not respond to those
of the other qas right he was still
attending some management meetings
still had some contacts that the company
was exploiting in some ways in short
people were expecting from him things
because of what had happened in the past
not because of his position or the
institutional version of what he should
be doing a third set of set of factors
structural so if you're if you're a
slave in this line you don't have much
choice and what you can do and and your
the expectations plated and you are you
know pretty pretty simple just keep on
pulling but if you're in some other
point in the structure of the
organization you may have much more
leeway and ability to influence and and
to interact with others in the
organization in some ways so an example
of this in the second company I studied
in the second group the head of
operations that I that I mentioned
before he had a unique position where he
was the contact of the whole group with
the computing center with the head of
the software group with the head of the
science group with database person with
we'll all of the people below him and so
that gave him more more ability to do
some things but it also placed on him a
lot of expectations coming from many
different ways these expectations just
to repeat come from his position in the
organizational structure not from from
from anything else and finally personal
factors everyone brings something
different to the role that they enact
right so it could be that you're not
very good at doing what you're expected
to be doing it could be that you're very
proactive and do far more than what is
expected of you and that performance
that divergence of your performance
against your original expectations
changes what people expect from you
the second company there was this this
guy a project administrator he was this
was really a clerk position he was
supposedly just in charge of you know
keeping track of the payroll and the
budget of the projects and so on but he
I mean the job was not satisfying for
him like that so he started taking on
more stuff and and the rest of the
people got used to that got used to him
knowing all the terms in knowing what
was the status of the bugs and and all
of that and keeping track of all of it
when he took some vacation time out an
application when he took a leave to
fulfill in another position in the in
the group project administration role
was was crumbling down and everybody was
because everybody was expecting stuff to
happen from the replacement of this guy
that was not happening by the time I was
spending time at that company they were
rerouted the the description of the
position so that the personal factors in
this case the the characteristics that
this person brought into the role became
official policy after after a few years
excuse me right so earlier I talked
about the difference between roles and
positions the we found both an overlap
in some ways between what a person is
expected to do by the group and what the
position is but also some mismatch and
we we came up with the with an
explanation for this your position your
title represents your placement in the
organizational structure so it's a
structural factor and it also defines to
a large extent the the institutional
expectations placed in you so you are a
project manager okay you're placed in a
certain position in the organization to
satisfy the expectations of a project
manager so structure and your title
represents you know you should be
managing projects so you should be doing
a certain kinds of thing
kind of things but your position does
not define anything does not have to do
with the historical and the personal
factors that I also talked about so a
lot of the distinction between what your
role is in practice and what your
official position is comes from the
difference between what you bring to the
to the organization and what the formal
policy of the organization is by the way
this is none of your recognizing this is
from the wire a TV show and it's full of
people that diverge from their positions
trying to do some other role that was
not formally placed on them and it
doesn't always end well for them all
right so we also asked ourselves what
makes a role evolve over time and there
are many things but we focused on to the
first one is organizational growth as an
organization grows sociologists tell us
and our data confirms this you have more
specialization and it is easy to see to
see why this would work in practice so
in the smallest possible company where
you have just one person doing
everything that person has you know that
person's role includes all the
expectations of the organization but as
that person you know keeps hiring other
people the expectations are more spread
out more specialized and by the time
when you reach a larger group you have
much heavier specialization or much more
detailed specialization than before so
it was that's one of the things that the
drives role evolution the other one I
briefly alluded to it before is the
mismatch between expectations and
behavior so either through a failure to
meet the expectations placed in you or
through contributing more than what's
expected from you the other people adapt
right they learn to expect the new
normal over time
I gave you several examples of this
already but just one more the head of
the science group in the second company
that I was talking about was hired as a
scientists just to you know do whatever
it is that scientists do but started to
get involved in software development
side of things without knowing anything
about it at start by the time that I
spent down with this company he was
attending all the all the meetings for
the development group chipping in into
what what the product should be doing
how it should be behaving whether the
user community think about it and he
became a very important voice within the
group just thanks to his son initiative
now people expect this from him if he
leaves they will they will miss that
heavily one we're finding and we're done
I we also looked at what kinds of media
people used based on the on the role
that they had and how they did they use
it a problem for this for this
observation was that you know these are
small companies completely co-located so
a lot of the interaction was
face-to-face but moving beyond the the
face to face what kinds of artifacts
people used to communicate well the
broadest medium used in both
organizations was the issue tracking
system okay but its use was not uniform
so and developers and QA people used it
a lot to have a conversation going
through the issue tracking system but
other people also interacted a lot in or
took a lot out of it in different ways
so for instance team leads we're
interested in the aggregate information
what's the overall activity going on
they get information from the issue
tracking system even though they don't
put a lot in the in it
product managers use it to keep track of
the general progress of particular kinds
of features the director of software
development in both places uses it to
get a very you know high level view of
things he uses more the dashboard than
anything else a project managers use it
so you know people all over use issue
tracking systems but if you just look at
who is communicating through it you
missed a lot of the people who are
listening or you know taking the
aggregate activity out of it we were
interested in this because of the of a
earlier research project that Andy
mentioned when he introduced me the one
we did here with Gino Vannelli and we
speculate that perhaps part of the
reason why sometimes software
repositories are incomplete or
misleading is that they're just
capturing one kind of role interaction
between just a few roles and missing all
the other people that are part of the
conversation but in a more passive sense
other media the use of other media was
more localized so for instance chat IRC
was used with some development teams
project managers didn't use it the
customer support people use Google Docs
to keep track of cases from from other
customers nobody else had access to
these documents email and phone were
more prevalent for managers developers
readily used either especially phone
okay so so what so I I went over a
theoretical framework to make sense of
roles in software organizations I argue
that looking just at the row level may
be a misdirection that we need to look
at the actual expectations placed on
people and to distinguish between what a
role is and what a position is and I
think at the very least this should give
us better foundations to talk about
different kinds of software
professionals and even though we're just
beginning to do this I think it would
help us to design better better studies
about organizational structure and
organizational design for instance
remember that table I showed you earlier
we could devise a survey or some study
based on something like that have it
self-reported instead of derived from
from interviews to make data collection
easier and from several people you could
get a three-dimensional matrix of what
people expect from each other and what
they think people expect from them and
start to analyze misunderstandings in
placement of expectations within the
organization so something like this I
think could lead to better role
definitions it could help to study
bottlenecks and deficiencies in the
organizational structure what kind of
expectations are just placed on one or
two people and we lose those people you
know the company's in trouble how to fix
that yeah finally some some brief
observations role-based differences in
media use so the fact that people in
different roles use different kinds of
media or use them in different ways
could point to a systematic omissions in
repository mining so that's something to
pursue later on if in your organization
you're concerned about role
specialization you're right to be
concerned and it's it's important to
realize that if you want a team of
generalists even though you're perhaps
having someone specialized briefly on
something and then come back to the
general group the way that agile
proponents advocate that short-term
specializations unless you actively try
to fight it could could lead into a more
heartbreak long-term specialization
troll specialization
and finally if you if we just take the
labels of the rolls if we just talk
about you know project manager developer
or product manager that may obscure the
the true contributions that people bring
into they into the into their teams if
you're if you're just the project
administrator you may not other people
may not realize all the other stuff that
you're bringing into vm into the project
and i think i will end there if there's
any other questions i'll be very happy
to take them plans are where an
additional research do I mean obviously
yeah but you know varying sizes of
organizations
larger organizations because I think
that's you know it's a good start but
what's interesting to me is as I talked
to some colleagues special hire some
people within Microsoft yeah especially
the generalization what you may think
that definitely tends to be a movement
well should say definitely cuz it's
anecdotal but to me into Italy that
feels me a movement towards trying to
generalize or at least there's more Bend
I feel I've been diagram between these
rules right and it's already break down
some of the walls yeah you mentioned not
just the the last point may about even
just the role contributions maybe not
being realized but they also the
potential contribution may also be
constrained by the right that's true
well yeah so to answer your question
definitely a studying a larger
organization is something that we would
like to pursue because you know where is
huge that that may there may be domain
specific things about rules that we
don't understand yeah so in the short
term in the fairly short term if all
goes as planned we're going to do
something similar with a particular
group at a very specialized in a very
specialized domain in a large company at
General Motors we're also pursuing other
replications of this in in other sites
what I should point out is the
theoretical framework if we got it right
should still apply but it would still be
interesting to see the variations and in
different settings the big one is we
expect to see more specialization in
larger organizations and even even
though you try to fight it yes
organization in Euros
we're putting expectations like codified
like written down anywhere or or did it
really appear that people just kind of
got expectations from regular people the
same role companies kind of inferred
with the expectations were to a very
large extent in both sides and there was
no formal no correct formal
representation of what the expectations
are the second side remember is publicly
funded so there the position has a
description for everyone that
description often does not match what
they're actually doing in the first
sight I got several people for instance
one of the product managers I was
talking about the one that has a PhD in
bioinformatics he says well I was I was
higher than as a product manager I
didn't know what a product manager does
and nobody told me I thought he says at
what a product manager should do is to
you know be in touch with with users and
with with the user community and kind of
tell people inside what would work and
what wouldn't work he was frustrated and
a bit confused by the amount of control
he was expected to have of the direction
of the product that he should be saying
you know working this not on that
instead of I think maybe this is a nice
ebony to pursue with time he learned you
know two to adapt he said his son
behavior to the expectations of people
placed on him right and the role became
more similar his role became more
similar to that of the other product
managers in the turn in terms of
defining what the what the team is going
to do but this came from trial and error
in his case and in many others in these
groups
so at the beginning you posed this
question this is there really a problem
here yeah we're done in your interviews
did it do these people express like a
desire to have a better understanding of
their own rules and expectations on them
or was it like yeah it's kind of fuzzy
but you know we're fine as you know dude
it doesn't need it yeah great question I
think so if I remember correctly nobody
said I would like a better definition of
what I should be doing now although i
would have liked it before when I was
figuring that I think in general people
like fussiness for themselves because
it's more convenient right I mean I
didn't know I was supposed to be doing
this so you can't blame me right so in a
sense you know it helps you to have that
fuzziness it doesn't help you when other
people have it and I did hear complains
that you know and know what so so I what
I got a lot of was stuff like especially
in the first company these folks should
be doing this you know X and they're not
doing it all the time we have to go in
and do it ourselves that that's not the
way it should be right so you'll I'm
just hypothesizing here but people it
would appear do not like concreteness on
their own descriptions but would
appreciate it on others people's
descriptions wasn't covered in the study
is on scoffs if there's some downsizing
a very small but let's say there's
another round of funding all sudden
a wanted to double their size and their
engineering team that and then again
like your first point is there a problem
what which roles do I hire what's the
ratio of people that hire and I think
that's where we might get into where
that fuzziness can help can get pop pop
yeah that's right yeah yes did you take
these results back through the companies
and
so what was the reaction i am taking
them next week I'll told you then so i
have a presentation with the first
company in on monday yeah so informally
the one that the only person i talked
this i talked about this with was the
director of software development nothing
here struck him a surprising him but
we'll see about the rest of the
organization i'll report back
thank our speaker okay thank you